choice in a must win a game and it's
handshakes and we're off with the
Armageddon we're off with the Armageddon
we see a handshake in Magnus against
abdor of and uh it looks like an E4
opening here and something else we Noti
is somebody checking off move numbers
and why is that important everybody at
move 60 their increment begins they get
one second added per move so you see
people standing with score sheets just
checking off each move that's played
important stuff and the players will be
looking over they will be seeking
reassurance later uh that they are
gaining that increment at move 60 and in
the meantime some very quick moves uh
almost a replica of their earlier game
Magnus here uh just I'm really surprised
I've got to say playing right down the
line that gave nbec a draw earlier in
the uh in the day I think he just wants
another long maneuvering battle Magnus
Carson but no surprises here nothing new
Under the Sun in this one as uh both
players getting off to a f start it
seems like they're very familiar with
one another and you see not Beck doing
his patented stare he looks up at Magnus
saying what do you want from me now
Magnus is the one on the clock so Tanya
in the early stages it seems like even
if we haven't looked at the position yet
advantage in favor of nybeck especially
because Magnus is the first to slow down
uh and the one thing when you're playing
against Magnus is you cannot allow that
to get into your head the fact that
you're playing against world number one
and I think that's exactly what this
younger generation does so well kind of
accelerated Rook lift in that one with a
white Rook landing on H5 but we'll get
to that this is Magnus gson against Abdu
satoro and quiet quiet stuff I did check
we're now on move 20 for the first 16
moves this was an exact replica of their
earlier game but nobec was the first one
to launch a surprise putting the Black
Knight on B6 forcing Magnus to think and
in the meantime we look at the clock
it's about a three and a half minute
difference here so less than it was to
start the game uh looks like Abu sator
in his comfort zone there's some
tactical opportunities for sure later in
the game if white plays Knight D5
opening up that Bishop to slice across
the board but what I like about magnus's
position is the Knight on B6 is
restricted by that pawn on B3 a pawn
three squares away from a night usually
wins that Showdown and you see notbe he
is thinking on magnus's clock yeah he's
thinking and magnus's clock and I think
the last move that he made is The Rook
lift to D7 we see it on our live board
right now and Magnus is the one with
head in hand trying to figure out a way
forward and I think the idea that nbec
has here is to try to transfer the queen
to the king side with Queen E8 and queen
G6 and that's why Magnus is going for
this queen side break creating chances
on the other flank yeah he's trying to
open up the position trying to uh at
least for the first time make Abdu
satoro think here it's starting to get
tactical it's really coming to life this
position I've said it before armagedon
chest there's two strategies with white
either you go really direct really test
your opponent from the off or you keep
as many pieces on the board as possible
and and only later changed the pace of
the game Magnus has gone for that latter
strategy finally he is initiating some
tension some threats Robert mentioned a
white knight planting itself uh in the
center on the D5 square and after St he
has to act energetically to fend off
that threat but the problem is he
doesn't have so much time because he may
have to make a critical moment and only
spend 30 seconds where in a classile
game he might spend 30 minutes I mean we
see this position here Knight E3 to D5
that looks extremely tempting as White's
next turn because you are just throwing
your knight in the opponent's rook's
face please please please take me on
that square and open up some diagonals
and files for my pieces this type of
position it looks very difficult for
black the eval bar may not be as
impressed as I am but I think Magnus
feels comfortable right now with the
white pieces wow and he's landed a
knight I'm really surprised abdor
allowed this one but okay he's trying to
trade off pieces later he'll try to
evict this Knight with a pawn and uh
Magnus meanwhile preventing that he's
putting pressure on this Black Knight to
stop the black C Pawn from ever moving
this KN it looks like a granite statue
right now on the center of the board
it's super powerful and uh pressure on
black uh this one looks easy to play for
white but really far from Clear what
Abdus Toro should be doing I don't like
Black's position and you may want to
play C6 you're not going to get that
anytime soon as you mentioned so I feel
like white has the easier plan moves
like Bishop to A5 that Bishop on D2 not
doing so much on its current Square so I
really like mag's position and his
4-minute lead on the clock is also
something I appreciate nearly five at
this point yeah still far from decisive
black is solid enough for now but no
easy moves I really like magnus's
position still I don't see a plan for
black I think that being under seven
minutes and being under some duress here
Magnus in great shape yeah Magnus in
great shape he's now pausing and then
he'll switch up the pace speed up once
he's decided upon a plan uh multiple
moves Bishop to A5 I quite like from
Robert you could push the white a pawn
forward Black's Knight is really
unstable right now um you can tradeoff
dark squ Bishops potentially but uh
Magnus spoiled for Choice Big Time
advantage and I think a bit of a
favorite right now uh in this Clash at
least still quiet but if things living
up it should favor white yeah huge
favorite I would say I really like this
position for white I think not you can
see his body language he's trying to you
know be stoic and say I've got this but
I'm just looking at it and I don't
really see Black's plan where some of
White's moves do seem much easier and
Bishop A5 one of the year he might stop
on B4 before eventually going to A5 but
I think that black has a difficult time
dealing with some of these threats and
you can never really take on D5 that
just helps white but a minute and a half
on this move that's quite a long thing
you've got to play on the clock as well
especially with NC's moves ideas not
being so clear for him it's critical for
Magnus to keep the pressure on Long
think strong think maybe if he comes up
with a good move but uh yeah Magnus in
the tank right now and I like uh nbec
how he was giving Magnus a bit of a
stare from time to time he looks at the
board he stares at Magnus he looks at
the board stairs at Magnus the Mind
Games now head in hands abdor he's
realizing that Magnus a bit unsure about
how to proceed in the end pushing his a
point very logical a trademark of
Carson's pushing his flank pawns like
this but uh still good for white love
that move because I kept looking at a
bishop move he says let me kick that
Knight out of B6 we have already
established that black does not want to
take that Knight on D5 to help white
improve the pawn structure and I'm going
to play A5 next to kick your knight out
of the B6 Square really really like how
Magnus is doing this yeah yeah Simple
Plan and a strong plan just to highlight
Robert if night takes night then
actually you could take in either
direction right now but at the very
minimum you can take like this land a
queen on C4 backward Pawn big targets
big Advantage wow some pressure on nbec
and the current position if black does
try to stop the threat you don't want to
really happily put your own Pawn on A5
because it can become such a big Target
for that Bishop on D2 as well a
long-term weakness so some difficult
decisions here to be made by nck does he
allow magnus's Pawn to advance to A5 or
create a weakness for himself by pushing
the awn we will check in on this I also
see no pieces for black like I see what
he's doing but I don't see where his
pieces are and it looks like it's a rook
end game actually where white is two
pawns ahead this has shades of Carlson
lavic from the first match yeah big
Shades there he was two pawns up as well
and all not all the rook and games are
drawn this is an exception as well white
simply has too many connected pawns uh
too many pass pawns and this at the
elevated level these players play at is
Elementary stuff wh's King is simply
going to join the party now he's going
to centralize Magnus he's the king of
end games as everyone knows and okay
first he targets this weak black ewn as
long as he leaves himself with two extra
pawns ideally connected Magnus is
guaranteed to win this one and look at
the clock as well hope slipping away
hope fading out for Abdu satoro uh
hopefully we get time later there were
some highlights some tactics uh earlier
in this game but Magnus full control why
is Magnus not in control it's rare
occasionally happens occasionally
happens but not today as he takes down
uh